ما ان يحل الظلام على منطقه الاشرفيه في
بيروت يبدا طوني بجوله في شوارعها
يستفيدو من خبرته كعسكريه السابق للمساهمه
في اعاده الامن الى احياء ترعرع فيها
هو واحد من 120 شابا يتوزعون على الارصفه
ليكون جزءا من عيون الاشرفيه الساهره بعد
ان عانت المنطقه خلال الاعوام الماضيه من
ارتفاع نسب السرقه
ان شاء الله
يعني كمان الشباب اللي عندنا
نتواصلت مع القوى الامنيه وحلوا الموضوع
بطل فيه سرقات تخفي كثير حتى في عالم
مطويات صار عم تتركها على الطريق
مع الازمه الاقتصاديه لم يعد عديد واعتاد
القوه الامنيه كافيا لمحاربه السرقات
فحول النائب نديم الجميل هذه الفكره الى
واقع بالتعاون مع جمعيه اشرفيه 28 على ان
يقوم الاهالي والتجار بدفع مبلغ رمزي
للشبان لكن مبادره عيون الاشرفيه كانت
محطه انتقادات خاصه من اعلام
على تواصل معهم بطريقه مباشره وهذا شيء ما
عنده جنس الامن الزيت الى بل بالعكس عنده
الوحيده التضامن الاجتماعي عن اكثر من
المواطنين انه همم احساس الامان
والاستقرار ما كان موجود ابدا
وفي كثير محلات كانت عم بتسكر
المكان بدها تقفلتها متاخر فمن هيدا
المنتظر للامن
وليد واحد من مئات من تعرضت لحالهم و
منازلهم للسرقات وهو يرى ان المبادره هي
حاجه للاهالي بعيدا عن انتقادات الامن
الذكي
المنطقه
سلمتهم
يبدو انها كانت كافيه لتراجع النسب
السرقات يتناوبوا ابناء الاشرفيه على
حمايه منطقتهم
يهدف الى حمايه الاهالي بعيدا عن اي
استفزازات مناطقيه واضمن قواعد حددتها لهم
القوه الامنيه الشرعيه